also hier ist noch ein riesen
Menschenauflauf man sieht hier nur
einzeln
du musst immer ganz kurz gucken pass auf
Nummer kurz ducken Schwenk mal hier
runter hier überall rum steht wir sind
nämlich auf dem Youtuber Treffen in Köln
es ist wahnsinnig und jetzt geht es
wieder darum ihr könnt meinen nächsten
Gast eine Frage stellen aber das sage
ich nicht selber das sagt er er selbst
und warum er sich gerade gedruckt habe
dass jetzt es ist ein Riese und hi Was
geht ab mein Name ich bin von Hamburg
und äh ja wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen
habt stellt sie und ich werde sie
beantworten
seid kreativ nicht 100 Fragen auf einmal
und kurz fasst euch kurz dann
beantworten möglichst viel also er auf
jeden Fall versprochen